I'm major Selva matthew mcconaughey
we're doing the autocomplete the wired
auto wire autocomplete interview well
basically what it is oh you know what it
is that uh where is interest Elba right
now it's Elba right now is in New York
where is Andrew Silva from London East
London
I'm a Hackney boy born born I actually
was born in Forest Gate Hospital where
is it gene what were you gene you know I
do that again yesterday I was DJed in
Derbyshire well where's this in
Derbyshire England where did you go to
school I went to barking College of
Technology to study drama Matthew
McConaughey that is I where was Matthew
McConaughey born
Uvalde Texas we move down when the first
Wendy's moved in when it did Matthew
McConaughey get all right oh where did
he get off yeah all right all right all
right first film I'm ever on dazed
confused I'm in the car about to do my
first scene ever on film it's not
unscripted
it was a scene that's in the movie where
Woodsen's hanging out in front of pool
hall girls walk by he reaches over slaps
on the backside his buddy says you got
to cut that out are you gonna go to jail
these steps floors there's no man that's
what I love about those high school
girls I get older but they stay the same
age so that line I'm like who is this
guy right yeah we my about what am I
about to myself officer Knight here
action and I look up and I look at
Mercer EBC across the way into myself I
go the fourth thing worse than about us
picking up chicks our stores everything
on the screen where is Matthew
McConaughey now same place edges elbow
was five minutes ago the same boat no no
no I love being
where is Matthew McConaughey's house as
we know almost kind of wherever our hat
is hangin tinnitus in New York City is a
juris Elva left-handed Aegis elbow is
not left-handed that's one of the
questions you guys are curious about on
that internet are united no I'm not
knighted but I do have what is called an
OBE after my name is Andres Velva in the
office I was in a season awk in the
American office yes is it just Elba in a
relationship yes great answer is injures
Elba related to Jessica Jessica is Alba
no but jessica is super fly as Matthew
McConaughey is Matthew McConaughey got
any bongos what doctor stroking it says
it's not am I married yes I am both a
professor well I do teach a class
created classy University of Texas so
that's very impressive but did not know
that man a Cavs fan more of a Cavs fan
now because my last job before was in
Cleveland so I got to hang out the whole
team a little bit but mainly a group of
Houston Rockets fan so you jumped ship
no I didn't go are so Chelsea hey
related to Woody Harrelson
oh geez in another life I think so
brother from another mother yes one of
the last great wild men ever walked this
earth what does injures elbow look like
this is what I look like in real life
what's your tattoo say I have like nine
tattoos this is a black star and a
lion's face inside of it and I'm half
carne and half Sierra Leonean in Ghana
they have a black star on their flag and
in Sierra Leone have a lion
what does get yourself I mean yourself
it doesn't mean anything it's just my
name my real name is actually a dresser
a Kuna Elba and that still doesn't mean
anything so what kind of coat does
inter-cell beware in Luther's office
sort of pea coat long thing made out of
really beautiful one and they
discontinued it apparently so you got
that one
yeah what football team does it yourself
support I am in guna Kuno is some of the
supports Arsenal does matter McConaughey
get free Lincoln's yes wear contacts no
those are your blue eyes babies in mind
then live in New Orleans we do not own a
home there is for my favorite cities in
the world there's my friend McConaughey
thing is the suburbs handsome absolutely
good question lady I don't know what
does Matt McConaughey eat okay I've got
a nice restaurant and they now say no no
we have a beautiful day a piece of it
dunno I don't know I want the tuna fish
salad please
is that it okay that's it fantastic
thanks for those questions Bazaar is
some of them are but you know the minute
it's nice to know what you're asking and
we love you see August 4th in the tiaras